大家好
歡迎來到咖啡
我是俊元
今天我們來跟大家討論一下
手沖咖啡
我們的咖啡粉
應該要磨多粗
這也是很常有觀眾朋友
在留言詢問我的一個問題是
我們的粗細應該要磨多粗
那其實就算像是我每天在接觸咖啡的人
我遇到一支新的咖啡
通常也是要經過很多次的測試
我們才能夠去抓到一個
最適合它的咖啡粉的粗細
所以其實常常有朋友在網路上問我說
該磨多粗的時候
其實我是很難回答這個問題的
因為我不曉得你使用的咖啡豆
或是你使用的器材是怎麼樣
所以我們其實很難直接告訴你要磨多粗
通常只能很籠統的告訴你說
我們大約是磨跟砂糖一樣的粗細
因為每一個人的磨豆機其實是不一樣
我知道其實很多朋友是希望
我直接告訴他磨豆機刻度調多少
但是問題是每個人的磨豆機不同
甚至你是同一個型號的磨豆機
都會因為每一台之間細微的差異
可能差一個刻度
它就有不同的粗細
所以通常我們還是要靠自己來判斷
把它磨的大概像砂糖一樣的粗細
通常是我開始測試的一個標準
所以等一下我第一壺咖啡我就會
像是我拿到一支新的豆子
我會先用一個最簡單
穩定的一個沖煮方式
然後磨到像這個砂糖一樣的粗細
那我們先來測試一下它標準的風味
其實它這樣子沖煮出來的風味
通常就不會太差
但是我們可以沖煮出第一壺之後
我們再試著去調整
怎麼樣去調整到一個更適合它的
咖啡粉的粗細
那我們先來沖煮第一壺咖啡
好 我們第一壺咖啡的咖啡粉
磨的粗細是跟那些砂糖差不多
那我會先用一個我們這邊習慣的沖煮方式
就會先悶蒸30秒
然後等一下我們就一次注水到我們要的量
那今天我們把它注到180克
然後用15克的咖啡粉
這樣子的比例
然後我們把它滴漏完
試試看它的風味
沖煮的過程當中當然我們也是一邊去觀察
它整個咖啡粉跟水結合的狀況
其實遇到一隻新的豆子的時候
我們其實要透過很多的觀察
不只是最後風味
我們要去試試看
其實在沖的過程當中
我們也可以去觀察一下
看它這個粉跟水結合的狀況
然後我們這個水注下去它比較膨脹的效果然後是不是粉有很快速的沉下去還是它會浮在上面其實這都是我們在觀察的一個指標
注水到180克
然後讓它滴漏完
通常這是我遇到一隻新的豆子
我會用這樣的方式來測試
那試喝之後
我們再來看一下是不是它的風味
可以再去做一些調整
它滴漏完的時間大約是1分40秒左右
所以這是滿正常的一個流速
其實我們在調整咖啡粉的粗細
其中有一項是會影響到它的流速
那如果流速太慢
總摧取時間太長
其實就會有過脆的這樣子的風險
所以我們在看總摧取時間的時候
也可以大概知道說
現在是不是一個適當的流速
那如果太快也不好
因為太快有可能會造成萃取不足
那可能風味會比較薄弱
或是帶一點酸澀感
好我們來試喝一下這壺咖啡
當我們拿到一支新的豆子
通常我會這樣子先去試著沖煮它
那這樣子出來的結果通常都不會太差
其實剛剛這樣喝起來
酸甜的比例濃厚度都還蠻不錯的
但是通常我不會滿足於
直接這樣沖好像就可以了
我會想要去嘗試看看
這隻豆子還可以發揮到什麼程度
所以這個時候通常我會把它再磨細一點試試看
因為再磨細一點
可以讓它的厚實度讓它的甜味呈現得更好
當然有可能如果磨得過細
它就會有苦澀味過脆的味道會出來
或是流速太慢浸泡太久
也是容易會過脆
但是我們稍微磨細一點挑戰看看
說不定這隻豆子可以萃取出更多好的風味
所以通常我嘗試的方向就是
如果當這杯沖煮出來
它是一個蠻平衡不錯的風味的話
我會去挑戰磨細一點看看
看它是不是可以萃出更多的東西
但是如果我這樣子沖出來
就已經有一點過脆的苦澀味
或是我們剛剛看它總萃取時間
如果拉得太長的時候
比如說超過兩分鐘或兩分鐘半的時候
那有可能這隻豆子的特性
它沒有辦法這樣子的除氣去萃取
那這個時候就會往粗的方向去調
所以當我們沖出來這杯咖啡
如果它是味道是OK的時候
我就會往細的刻度去嘗試看看
看能不能去萃出更多的味道
讓它的風味更豐富
好我們在調細之後我們要注意的第一個當然是它的流速會不會變得過慢因為流速過慢就會造成總萃取時間變太長
那就容易過脆
那模式本身它就可以萃取出更多的味道
我們希望的當然是能夠萃取到更多的甜度
它豐富的滋味跟它的厚實感
那不希望過度到它是過脆的
那我們還是一樣先用最基本的
我們悶蒸30秒後沖煮的方式
那當然沖煮的手法都是可以調整的
像我們上次有去討論就是
除粉跟細粉萃取出來
如果我們用沖煮的手法
把它調整到萃取率跟濃度一樣的時候
其實是可以做得到的
但是它也有可能會讓這個風味品嚐起來
像我自己是覺得如果用細粉快沖的話
雖然它的萃取率跟濃度是一樣
但是它的層次感感覺會沒有這麼的好
所以像我們在沖煮的時候
我們現在調細一點的時候
也是要注意這一點
有的時候雖然它是沒有過脆
沒有苦澀味
可是讓它的味道過度集中
那它的層次感變得沒有這麼好的話
那有兩種方式
一種是說我們沖煮的手法上
可能我們可以再調整
那另外一種是我們也可以
不要磨到那麼細
我們就回到我們剛才最初的
如果原本的味道是
比較好的話
我們就回到上一個粗細度
所以其實當我們在遇到一支新咖啡的時候
到底應該要磨多細
我們也是會經過這樣子反覆的嘗試
然後找到一個最適合它的粗細度
所以很多朋友在網路上要問我
直接磨一支豆子啊
或是它在沖滾的時候
該磨到什麼樣的粗細度的時候
其實真的是很難直接回答啦
因為連我們自己在現場遇到的這些豆子
我們都是需要經過多次的嘗試
才會知道說它到底適合多粗或多細
所以我們剛剛看到磨細一點之後
它總萃取時間是有拉長一點
大約是1分50秒左右去萃取完
那我們來試試喝看看這壺咖啡
我們剛才把它磨細之後的這壺咖啡
我現在喝起來
我覺得它的甜感跟厚實感的確是有提升
但是它的苦味有一點點出來了
雖然沒有很明顯
可是我覺得它的苦味跑出來一點點了
那這個就是看個人喜好了
如果你喜歡非常厚實的風味的話
再有一點點苦味可以接受的話
其實你就可以用這樣的顆細度來磨
那如果你覺得咖啡盡量是完全不要讓它有苦味
然後要喝比較清爽的口感的話
我們就可以回到上一個粗細度那這樣子來沖煮的時候它咖啡是整個酸甜很平衡那幾乎是完全不帶苦味的一個風味所以我們在調整咖啡的粗細的時候
其實就是去測試它的風味
那看怎麼樣的粗細最適合這支咖啡豆
所以它會因為每一支的咖啡
跟你的沖煮的方式
甚至沖煮的器具
你用什麼濾杯
都是有關係的
所以這個很多朋友在網路上直接留言問我
該怎麼磨的時候
我真的很難回答的原因就是
我連直接接觸到的豆子
其實也都是需要經過好幾次的測試嘗試
慢慢調整到一個我覺得最好的搭配
包括甚至連濾杯濾紙
這些器材
怎麼樣把它搭配出一個好的風味
所以當如果只是很籠統的問說
該磨多粗多細的話
我只會回答說
你就先磨到大約像砂糖一樣的粗細開始來嘗試
所以我自己在嘗試這個粗細度
它整個流程大概就是我會先從一個最基礎的
就是從這個砂糖的粗細
來用最基本的沖法開始來沖煮看看
如果當這個風味我覺得是OK的
沒有苦澀味的話
我就會先磨細一點點
去挑戰萃取更多東西出來看看
說不定這隻豆子還有一些我可以萃取出來
還剛才沒有萃取到的味道
讓它的滋味更豐富
那模系的過程當然它有可能流速會變慢
總水準時間會變長
可能比較容易過脆這些問題
或者說它風味可能會比較集中
層次感比較差這些問題
我們都可以去試試看
那如果有新的風味出來
可是又伴隨一些可能過脆的問題的話
那我們就可以利用一些充足的手法
去解決這些問題
然後去把這些新的風味把它保留下來
那另外一個方向是說
萬一我們第一次像砂糖這樣的出戲
就覺得它流速太慢
然後會過脆
有這些苦澀味的話
那我們就可以往粗
再往粗一兩個顆度
試試看去磨
然後這樣子用不同的顆度
去萃取的時候
看看它是不是會有不好的風味
當然如果你一直調整
它一些不好的風味一直在的話
也有可能是豆子本身的問題
好 所以當我們在手沖咖啡
想要幫它萃取出
最好風味的時候
其實在調整
咖啡粉的粗細度
也是需要經過不斷的嘗試
去找到一個最適合這支豆子
跟最適合你的沖煮器材的刻度
那是今天我們跟大家分享的
手沖咖啡粉應該要磨得多粗的一個內容
那之後我們會有更多咖啡分享的影片
請大家訂閱我們的頻道
我們下次見
掰掰